bolivia celebrado su aniversario patrio
en una tensa sesión legislativa donde el
presidente luís arse concurrió a dar un
mensaje al país el mandatario ha
destacado que su gobierno está sacando
al país de la crisis luego del
desmantelamiento del gobierno de jeanine
áñez que según dijo fue un gobierno de
facto
arze además destacó las medidas de su
gestión como por ejemplo el bono contra
el hambre para las personas más
necesitadas y el impuesto a las grandes
fortunas para los sectores más pudientes
del país asimismo anunció que
próximamente dará a conocer un plan de
empleo masivo para aminorar los efectos
de la crisis económica en el plano de la
salud ar se ha prometido que hasta
diciembre el 90% de la población mayor
de 18 años estará vacunado
también ha señalado que su gobierno a
destino ha destinado un presupuesto de
257 millones de dólares para enfrentar
la pandemia el discurso fue
constantemente interrumpido por los
opositores en momentos en que se hacía
mención al anterior gobierno como si
fuera un gobierno de facto
gobierno golpista los opositores
gritaban que en realidad el más cometió
un fraude y los masistas respondían que
los opositores son golpistas todo este
ambiente de tensión se vivió en el nuevo
edificio de la asamblea legislativa de
bolivia que fue inaugurada este 6 de
agosto y que tuvo un costo de 72
millones de dólares costo que también
fue motivo de polémica entre
oficialistas y opositores